- [Voiceover] Kleiber's law, above,
relates the basal metabolic rate, B,
measured in kilocalories per day,
of an animal to its body mass, M,
measured in kilograms.
If the body mass of an
elephant is 10 to the sixth
times that of a mouse,
which of the following
best compares their basal metabolic rates?
Alright, well, let's think
about this a little bit.
So, let's just say B sub lowercase M
that the basal metabolic rate of a mouse,
well, that's going to be equal to 70
times the body mass of a mouse,
that's why I wrote the subscript
lowercase M, for mouse,
to the zero point seven five.
Now, based on that, what's going to be
the basal metabolic rate of an elephant?
Well, the basal metabolic
rate of the elephant
is going to be 70 times, I could write
the mass of an elephant to the
zero point seven five power,
but we know that the mass of an elephant
is 10 to the sixth times that of a mouse.
So, instead of writing
the mass of an elephant
right over here, I could instead write
10 to the sixth times the mass of a mouse,
to the zero point seven five power.
And once again, I don't want this notation
to confuse you since I'm referring to
B for a mouse and B for an elephant,
I'm using the subscripts to differentiate.
This is the basal metabolic,
the basal metabolic rate
for a mouse, this is the basal metabolic
rate for an elephant.
This is the body mass of a mouse,
this is the body mass of an elephant,
which is 10 to the sixth
times that of a mouse.
I could have written, I
could have, over here,
this is the same thing as
the mass of an elephant.
We know that the mass of the elephant
is, or of an elephant, is 10 to the sixth
times that of a mouse.
And the reason why I did that
is once you write it this way,
we can now express this in terms of
the basal metabolic rate of a mouse.
What am I talking about?
Well, let's use a little
bit of exponent properties
to rewrite this.
So, this is going to be equal to 70.
And then all of this stuff
in, that I'm squaring off
in green, well, if i have
the product of two things
raised to an exponent,
that's the same thing
as raising each of these two exponents
and then taking the products.
So, this is gonna be 70
times 10 to the sixth,
to the zero point seven five,
times the mass of a mouse to
the zero point seven five.
And now I can rearrange it.
This is going to be equal
to, stay true to the colors.
70 times the mass of a mouse
to the zero point seven five power.
And then you're going to have this thing.
Times.
So, 10 to the sixth to the
zero point seven five power.
If I raise something to an exponent
and then raise that to an exponent,
that's just like raising
the 10 to the product
of six times zero point seven five.
So, what's six times
zero point seven five?
Let's see, that is going
to be, that is going to be
four point five.
One way to think about it, that's gonna be
three fourths of six.
So, zero point seven
five is three fourths.
So, six times three over four
is going to be 18 over four,
which is the same thing
as four and a half.
So, raising 10 to the sixth power
and then raising that to
the zero point seven five,
that's the same thing as raising 10
to the four point five power.
Now, why is this interesting?
Well, this part of the
expression right over here
is the basal metabolic rate of the mouse.
So, this is equal to the basal
metabolic rate of the mouse
times, times 10 to the four point five.
So, what we're able to
show, just like that,
is that the basal metabolic
rate of an elephant
is 10 to the four point five times
the basal metabolic rate of the mouse.
So, let's see if any of
these choices say that.
The basal metabolic rate of an elephant
is zero point seven five
times that of a mouse?
No, it's 10 to the four point
five times that of a mouse.
So, let's rule that one out.
The basal metabolic rate of the mouse
is 10 to the four point five
times that of an elephant.
Nope, doesn't make any
sense 'cause this is saying
the mouse has a higher metabolic rate,
basal metabolic rate in terms of how many
kilocalories per day it burns.
You wouldn't have to do any math,
you just say this seems crazy that a mouse
would burn more calories than an elephant.
The basal metabolic rate of an elephant
is 10 to the four point
five times that of a mouse.
Well, that's exactly what we came up with.
The basal metabolic rate of an elephant
is 10 the sixth times that of a mouse.
And we already know that that's
not going to be the case.
Now, another way that
you could have tackled it
is you could have just looked at this.
You could have just looked at this
and said, okay, look, if I increase M
by 10 to the sixth, if I
increase it by a factor
of 10 to the sixth, I'm gonna increase B
not by a factor of 10 to the sixth,
but by a factor of 10 to the sixth
to the zero point seven five.
To the zero point seven
five, and 10 to the sixth
to the zero point seven
five is the same thing
as 10 to the sixth times
zero point seven five.
Which is equal to 10 to
the four point five power,
which we have right, right over here.
So, these first two,
you could have actually
probably knocked out just off of
a little bit of deductive reasoning.
And even this last one to some degree
'cause you can say look, you know,
if I increase this by a certain factor,
because I'm raising this to an exponent,
this, the basal metabolic
rate won't increase
directly by that same factor.
So, but either way, we were able to
figure out exactly, as well.